this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be unto you this is
the greeting of Jesus this is the
greeting of Moses this is the greeting
of all the messengers of God check it up
in the Bible all the messengers of God
they call people to Islam Islam what yes
Jesus was a Muslim did you know that yes
he called people to acquire peace by
submitting your will to God's will this
is Islam you got a got might have got
confused with the Arabic but you know
what you're gonna even learn more if you
just open your mind humble your heart
and we're here to help you develop a
better understanding the topic today is
extremism extremism is there such a
thing as radical Islam extremist Muslims
and you hear all these other cliches and
mantras out there and what do we really
have to say the mainstream Muslims those
99% that we represent and today we're
going to be discussing these very
important issues here on the d show so
you don't want to go Noah we'll be right
back
with the author of the lies about
Mohammed a man must oppose aid we'll be
right back sit tight this is Dean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I'll make one piece becomes 11 cuts
how are you brother I am good thank God
thank God and we started as we always do
with peace
some people would try to have other
people think that we're against peace
but we start with P through peace we're
seeking peace what's the truth here are
we for peace or against peace actually
if you look at Islamic law if you're any
scholar of Islam with whatever worth
you'd understand that the main theme of
Islamic law is peace and peace pretty
even Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
made it a condition upon the believers
to get into paradise spread peace
amongst yourselves
that's the Prophet of Islam you get me
the prophet of FoxNews the prophet of
you know whatever channel they can say
whatever they want but if you're talking
about Islam the Prophet of Islam said
spread peace and that's the only
condition that you would be brought to
paradise go ahead please another example
which is actually is really telling of
the meaning of peace in Islam that your
immediate circle of acquaintances and
every living soul around you you have to
shower them with peace prov muhammad saw
asylum has this core equitation he said
to commit adultery with 10 women is
easier than to commit adultery with the
wife of your neighbor and when you look
at it logically adultery adultery it's
an abomination in Islam how is it 10
times is less and easier and punishment
then committed it with your neighbor's
wife because your neighbor is your
immediate circle of mandated peace and
if you know the things is brought out
and this clash that would destroy the
peace in whatever town Village City
whatever it is that you're doing and
that peace immediate peace is more
important than the up of a nation itself
so peace printing is the most important
thing about Islam and one of the common
factor of bashing Islam which is a very
old military technique is to attack you
and use strength points so you would
notice that it's lamb is very supportive
and persuasive a mandates peace they
would tell you it's a religion of
terrorism
it's Lomb uplifts and brings and gives
rise to women unprecedented in our
time and definitely in this middle of
the seventh century oh it's oppressive
to women it's subjugating to women islam
it give had tolerance for minorities
like no history or culture I had ever
seen who Islam is oppressive to
minorities and the anti-christian
anti-jew 's and and they kill the
believers or anyone who you know and
again and again it's totally opposite to
the truth lie after lie after lie yes
well do we have to take some
accountability what I want to say is and
the media doesn't help and you'll see
earlier they had this Christian who was
talking about burning the Koran now he
only had what like 25 30 followers
whatever the case but the media gave all
the attention to him but the Christians
came out and said he don't represent us
so you might have a few crackpots you
might have a few people who might be
trying to you know say that they're
doing things in the name of Islam what a
half a percent a percent now what I'm
saying is does this 1% represent the
mainstream of 99% of Muslims all over
the world no one had ever said that as
crazy and out of the general venue of
Christianity as Terry Jones that pastor
from Florida was no one claimed that he
represents an extreme part of
Christianity or there's a radical
Christianity that he represents
everybody said that he's out of his mind
is extremist he does not resent that is
this is a crime of extremism that he is
committing personally that has no
reflection on Christianity itself and I
have many pastor and Christian leader
friends that would tell that but the
problem that comes to Islam they tell
you this radical Islam there's no
radical Islam the radicals there's no
criminal Islam or Islamic jihadists or
Islamic terrorists if they're terrorists
and they are terrorists is nothing that
conducive for terrorism in Islam
whatsoever and we can prove by for an
and Sunnah a prophet mohammed salim said
letters do do fails to do mahalik do not
go to extremes do not be extremist so
Allah would bring extreme conditions and
Punishment upon you totally forbidden
don't be extreme don't be extreme it's
even in the religion itself do not kill
yourself and pray and do not kill
yourself and fasting not
kill yourself in reading the Koran
totally forbidding and this instances
with this for problem our Messiah even
doing the righteous thing that mandated
things and the religion if you do too
many of them and take it to an extreme
totally forbidden and actually that
would bring up punishment from God upon
you do not go to extremes the correct
highly to promise I said and there of
course you never hear quoted on Fox News
in a lot of vehicle new Hepworth coffin
embryo new allah subhanaw taala is
gentle and kind and he likes kindness
and mercy in everything and about
everything and he rewards for kindness
and mercy like he does not reward for
anything else there is a slap that is
the prophet of islam this is amazing
amazing i want to show you just to show
the tolerance in islam and these things
and and then I'm bringing not just
proofs and examples from Islam they are
unprecedented in the history of mankind
promised asylum is sitting in his Masjid
and the mosque holy sacred place with
the prophet of God worships and all of a
sudden a man walks in he wanted to learn
about Islam he's a bad one he walked
from a long distance so he felt that he
wanted to urinate what would the man do
he chose the part where Prophet Muhammad
SAW said understand and lead prayers and
started urinating people got so angry
this might be obviously someone who's
not Muslim and he came to dissipate and
and you know curse and offend Islam and
the Prophet of Islam and they wanted to
stand up and you know the beat the man
or take him out of the message or
something promised I said I'm asked him
not to touch him wait till he finish
your dating then he asked him to bring a
pocket for which is the way to clean
things and poured it on that what the
man had done and then said the man down
this is our religion our religion is a
religion of cleanliness this is how to
be clean this is how not and so on and
so forth till the man accepted Islam the
Prophet never told them why did you do
this
prognosis I've never yelled at him and
look at the tolerance in the mosque this
is what the Prophet would do this is
amazing and what I said earlier is that
we need to take some accountability
because we are not really living Islam
the way that the Creator wants us to
live it
mean lot of us are following different
cultural practices were not establishing
a relationship with our neighbors
inviting them to the Masjid Amma's and
helping them understand and clearing
these misconceptions and you know
actually that brings me to another point
a Christian or an atheist or a Jew or a
Hindu American whatever he is that most
likely from my experience because he was
not exposed to Islam had he learned
about Islam the waiters at least have
the choice
the outcome would have been totally
different all the Muslims that I know
that are objective that that you know
have open minded when they were
Christians or non-muslims
you bring the truth to them they figure
over they read the facts their research
had they come back with their own
decision so the fact that someone is not
Muslim they were not blessed in my own
opinion over the Blessed that we had me
and you it's like some allah subhanaw
taala god bliss is someone with a
fortune or money and someone else not
someone is rich someone is poor what do
you do there's something called charity
you have to give from the blessings that
he have and give to the one that he was
not blessed with it the knowledge of our
Islam the true religion of allah
subhanaw taala
creator of heaven earth was blessed to
us gift from that knowledge to people
whether they accept or not at least give
him the choice now do we have in our
history when you look at the Prophet
peace be upon him his life the way he
invited people to Islam the way he had a
dialogue and he debated or however he
did it now today and I'm talking about
that small group let's say of half a
percent or percent which the media the
same way or even that big not even not
even that so the way it's the same way
they this this radical individual who
wanted to burn the Koran and the good
Jewish and Christians they came up and
they were against this so now those
people who are out there let's say
screaming Arabic words and they're you
know having other hate rhetoric that's
coming out of their mouths and the media
goes in and takes a picture of this and
then they show it to the world does this
represent us does not represent us if
the Prophet was there he was condemned
that ranting walking and marches even
when the the characters of promise oh I
seldom and people started to go in
rallies and you know
did damage to stores totally honest
lamech and totally forbidden by Islam a
Muslim does not get angry and rant and
do things like that
a Muslim is a rational person a Muslim
is a peaceful person a Muslim would
would take of justified measures not
measures of anger or of extremism or
rational behavior against anything even
though if he was justified that is not
Islamic whatsoever so flipping cars
breaking windows you know rioting and
looting was a totally honest Lamech and
a totally forbidden by Islam and what
happens and I want to give an analogy
for this and I you know I said this and
then on a talk show what if I go with a
video camera to the South Bronx in New
York which an area that sometimes cops
are afraid to go to there's certain
Bloods that the cops would not even
drive there and take a video camera and
shoot and you know take footage of the
crimes and the what happens there and
claim that you know what there are
Americans this is America you know and I
know that this is not America but if I
take that extreme example and generalize
it and impose it upon 1.6 billion people
that's exactly the same way they go to
the rural areas in Afghanistan or
Pakistan or any other countries where
poverty is poking you in the eye people
who do not even know sometimes the
basics of Islam and show as if this is a
slam there's 57 Muslim countries yes
women do not drive in Saudi Arabia
they're driving the other 56 countries
yes there's people that do these
practice and oppressive to women in
certain places they are criminals in the
eye of Islam you should be the best to
your women your wife your mother your
daughter your sister you bringing me the
picture of the criminals in straw inside
a high-security prison and saying this
is the American population or the Muslim
population that is as deceptive as
camping definitely let's take a break
and we'll be back with more here in the
Dean show I don't see him here in Jannah
Allah opens a window so he can see his
friend in hell he looks at his friend
doesn't it you ok can I pull you out he
doesn't say that I said man you almost
took me to the party with you you're the
one used to crack jokes with me about
religion you know that you know that guy
and then now imagine this guy who's in
Jannah looking at this and saying
god I didn't listen to you because for a
second there I was thinking about it he
just saw Hellfire he comes back into
Jannah and it's like he just got here
for the first time the words in the
Quran are amazing nobility are we not
gonna die anymore
really oh wait you already knew that
he's a juggler when he saw a glimpse of
Hellfire the most beautiful thing you
could appreciate about Jenna first and
for like it's a reintroduction to Jenna
was the first thing he says not gonna be
tortured there's no more pain does the
second thing he appreciates why because
he just saw what pain looks like back
here on the D show with Imam was
toughies aid and we're talking about
extremism and you mentioned earlier that
the last and final messenger sent to
mankind of Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him who was a brother to Jesus
Moses Abraham and they all taught the
same religion - same way of life submit
your will to God's will this is Islam so
Muhammad he warned peace be upon him
against the stream ISM he warned against
this right this is a fact yes all right
did he say anywhere to go strap Obama
kill innocent people totally the
opposite indiscriminate killing of
innocent people is the most punishable
crime in Islam
raku Islam we mentioned it earlier
there's such a thing which radicals yeah
they're criminals they're crazy people
there's no radical Islam so why do you
have these people on the Fox News and
CNN and they'll keep saying radical it's
not the it's these Muslims are ok but
it's the radical Islam that we need to
worry about what there's no radical
Islam you know they say that this is you
know radical Islam and this is not
radical Islam there's radicals there's
criminals there's crazies but that has
nothing to do with the religion itself
Islam itself as a religion mandates
peace the matter of fact proper moments
as I've said if you're right and arguing
something with another person even
though you're right if you hold back the
arguing which is gonna lead to
confrontational ISM and and problems
then the Prophet Muhammad SAW Salim is a
guarantor of a place in there is heaven
for you in paradise give you an example
problem asylum as two men Mars of Japan
and Abu Salah sorry too
and open the country with him into his
lamp this is what he told him this is
the advice of romances and yes Sarah
what a [ __ ] Sarah
bashira well it's an affair make it easy
for people do not make it difficult and
tell people about the glad tidings of
allah subhanaw taala more than his
punishment there is a slight make it
easy the gradually of Islam he told him
the way to attract the people of Yemen
to Islam first tell him about the
oneness of allah subhanaw taala if they
accepted tell him that he has an
obligation upon you that you would pray
the five prayers a day if they pray then
tell him that the poor allah subhan
allah mandated that the poor has the
right over the care and charity in your
own mind
look at that gradually and the ease of
Islam many times in the one had that
prophet Moses and performed was hatchet
over there
people come to and hatch is a sequence
of things people come to promise I said
I did this before that or I didn't do
this whatever person that came to
prophet mama says I'm doing things wrong
were out of sequence
prophet Moses Allah answered if a large
do with Allah subhanAllah except make it
easy for people a lot of Hannah Tala
create the religion in the Quran you
read Allah who become a loose Rock what
I really become are lots of hands I
wanna make easy things easy for you
facilitate things for you not want to
make it difficult for you so if I lost
somehow that does not make it difficult
for me which human being there is
there's gonna be difficult for me verses
go to extremism and kill people and you
know imposes lamb and they have to
convert Islam like what they claim out
of date so how do you answer now because
every time you turn on the news
they'll say okay you know their
attribute a lot of these let's say
events that are going on and someone
blowing themselves off killings and
people I say this is radical Islam these
jihadist jihadis and other things like
this you know one of the most baffling
things is that only the bettors of Islam
think that criminals are so credible
that whatever they say is the truth so
the crazy person or a criminal or an
extremist or whatever has said that I do
this in the name of Islam and this is
Islam oh he's correct let's quote him
that's Islam and that that's what it is
who said that Islam is defined by
criminals who said that
freedom er or Charles mance and other
people to tell us what the American
Constitution is or who's Thomas
Jefferson is you want to know about
Islam read the quote and read the
quotations of the Prophet of Islam don't
go to criminals and tell me oh that's
another brand of Islam let me break
something used to them there's only one
Islam there's only one God there's only
one or n there's only one last prophet
of God you want to know about Islam that
Islam is there you want to make a new
brand of Islam call it anything but
don't come to our faces and tell us
that's a new brand of its land because
there's none can you say I mean we got
to be fair now if we wouldn't say
radical Christianity is there such a
thing as radical Christianity know that
you know people have committed crimes in
the name of Christianity more than I can
that the the the victims of the Crusades
mainly Muslims and some Jews six million
people at the time on the population of
the world was not even 1/10 what it is
right now and not one Muslim country
seen retaliation against local
christians christians in egypt christian
of morocco christian no one said oh
you're christian - let's kill you
because you know these people were
criminals there were thieves under the
banner of christ who is the last person
to be associated with them and
subhanAllah you go to the today's Bible
Matthew 22 7 people come to Jesus peace
be upon them and say O Lord in your name
we prophesized in your name we did
miracles in your name we did so many
charities and Jesus peace be upon him in
today's Bible say depart from here you
evildoers I got nothing to do with you
you got nothing to do with me what is
the reason they prophesize they made
Dawa they invited people to Christianity
they built churches they give charity in
his name where's the problem the problem
is in his name anything can not be
accepted unless it is for the sake of
God he was a Messenger of God and he
knows everything is only worth that is
being done for the sake of God and he
said I got nothing to do with you so no
extreme Islam no radical Islam an
individual might do some things that
aren't in accordance with Islam so we
have to separate that is a very these
people are severely punished by Islamic
law themselves you go and
you know kill people innocent children
for whatever justifications that you
have totally forbidden by slam totally
forbidden I want to give you another
story especially about suicide bombing
because people ask about that can you
hold on we're gonna take a break and
we'll go ahead and have you explain this
story here on a date she'll be right
back
and if we're gonna worship something I
figured I might as well worship the
creator instead of any of the creations
now in upon investigating the religions
I remember finding out the meaning of
what Islam is what Muslim is those who
surrender their self to God is a Muslim
those who surrender submit to God God's
will die see Islam was pure it was just
you just pray to God you create when the
outside everything looks good you see
the hundred thousand dollar cars you see
a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here our job to go
into someone's heart and change their
heart your job is to topi what the truth
is and then the alley of it is while
we're sitting here while I'm sitting
here constantly paying for the disease
to cure was free
back here on a Dean show with email most
of his aid before we went to a break you
were talking about the story about the
suicide bomber yes because that comes up
a lot and a lot of people use that as an
excuse that you know these people claim
that they're jihadists are doing
something that is in the name of jihad
or Islam so Islam is conducive for
terrorism and they couldn't be further
from the truth at a battle with prophet
Moses allah the companions of prophet
Moses Elam noticed a man that was
fighting so bravely that they actually
had to stop and come near to him and go
to Prophet Muhammad SAW Selim and
praised the man this man definitely will
get a tremendous reward from Allah for
the parade the courageous way that he
was fighting rough Muhammad's is a lemon
this is one of his premonitions miracles
he said no he is in Hellfire so people
were shocked how calm so based on that
they followed the man around in battle
what happened the man who was fighting
for the sake of God so courageously
received a fatal wound and it was so
painful he did not want to wait to be
nursed could not take the pain and
committed the ultimate sin of taking his
own soul that only allah subhanaw taala
would take and leant against his sword
and kill himself committed suicide
killed only himself and committed
suicide Prophet Mohammed Salim said that
he is into Hellfire imagine now and this
man received the wound while he was
fighting truly in an army man to man
face to face for the sake of Allah
subhana Tom imagine that I was strap
bombs around myself and definitely go
there knowing that I'm going to kill
myself
that man did not wish to be hit or you
know fatally wounded like that but it
just so happened no I strap myself with
dynamite knowing that definitely I'll be
killed and I go amongst innocent
civilians that Prophet Muhammad say
Salaam forbade you only fight the people
who carrying arms and fighting you even
someone who is strong and able to fight
but he's not carrying a sword or a gun
against you you're not to touch him he's
a civilian and put myself amongst the
fires and killed civilians and and and
innocent people indiscriminately while
killing myself
you tell me where would I go
according to Islamic law to the Hellfire
as perform homicide seldom then come
someone who commits that horrible crime
that sends you to hell fired directly no
matter what kind of deeds you've done
and say you know what I'm doing this in
the name of Islam would that make it a
brand of Islam would that make it now
he's the Prophet of Islam I should
listen to him committing that crime and
I should not listen to the Prophet of
Islam himself now someone says you know
what look look look you know over here
Jesus peace be upon him he taught turned
the other cheek but you have your
messenger over here who's a warlord and
encouraging violence how would you
refute this look at the [ __ ] end and
look at the true meaning of turning the
other cheek and turning the other cheek
were not sure that it was said by Jesus
peace be upon him Christian scholars
will tell you that textual critics in
Christianity will tell you that the
great iron surat al-imran where a lot of
how do i specify who are the people that
are there places are preserved and saved
now in general what stereogram and
furthermore become Oh Janet an ardent
semi-wet Oh Lord that Wilma talk in
raise the forgiveness from your God and
a paradise that is already prepared for
those who feel a loss of Hannett out of
the truly pious
who are they what are their
characteristics one and levena Universal
Torah those who spend in when they have
the money one would think so tight they
help the poor and they give charity for
the sake of God and who else well called
the mean Eliza well - earnest and those
who repress their anger holder
aggravation pardon and forgive people
and always Allah likes those who does
righteous that who do righteous deeds so
how should in our last minute that we
have how should a Muslim one who now is
possibly feeling like he has no other
exit he feels like now you know the
whole world is against him the
Islamophobia is on the rise and now he
feels like maybe you know he might have
seen something that's not correct and he
feels like maybe the easy way out now
maybe he's not even married not as you'd
marry single you really frustrated and
then he goes on and thinks about putting
a bomb like the guy who
the times for Time Square incident right
yeah which obviously Islam again has
nothing to do with the Islam condemns it
so to prevent someone from going to this
extreme what do you got to say first of
all look at Islam itself don't tell me
that he did something righteous or
avenging real crimes one of the reasons
that men start to commit that crime that
our unfortunately American army went to
of civilian village in Afghan Pakistan
with the claim that there's some Taliban
people there or some terrorists there or
whatever that the claim and bombed
everyone good bad and ugly and he's seen
that some of them were his relatives
whatever the reason was and he was
incensed by that and these are the
people are easy to recruit that's
another thing out of honesty also these
people don't go crazy enough to kill
themselves on innocent people because
they had a bad brand of ice cream or a
bad tasting brenigan because they're so
oppressed in Palestine and in
Afghanistan and Iraq that it's very easy
for the evildoers to recruit these
people and put them into these horrible
crimes so remind everyone no matter what
it is you deal with people with you
manners promises and has this beautiful
and it shows the civility of Islam this
beautiful hadith he said in a lotta you
have Bonnie Hakuna I had to come in man
a lot of Canada does not like any one of
you to be like a mirror is that accident
a co Lahey hacen if people would treat
him good he would treat him good or
treat him in a in the same fashion
whatever I said well like I said if they
treat him bad he'll treat him worse so
you're not an initiator of your manners
you are a reflection of other people
behavior in other manners you don't have
the manners of Islam yourself people can
deal with you whichever way they can
deal with you you deal with people with
the manners of Islam the manners of the
Prophet of Islam and that is very
important
amazingamazing last closing comments and
suggestions for those people who like
what we have to say and you know what
they're getting enticed to look into
Islam or what do you got to tell him
and so Allah I offered the book the lies
about Muhammad how we were deceived into
Islamophobia I want an answer of the
question of brother Eddie read it learn
it for yourself there's an index in the
back that shows the
allegations against the Prophet and it
shows you the page where you can refute
that learn it
do not be defensive in the office I say
this to all brothers and sisters walk
tall you are the worshipper of the true
God and the true message of the creators
of heavens and earth tell about it do
not be defensive people of all kind and
makes and shapes and ideology walk tall
with weird piercings and colors and and
behaviors and they tell you I'm
different and they want to debate you
anytime you want to open the subject of
personality you are Muslim tell of the
message of Islam leniently nicely
politely it is a mandate and it is a
requirement even being pragmatic and
practical in the environment that we
have we all that to our American
brothers and sisters each other thank
you very much Heidi Allah rewards that
later and with that said we come to
another episode of the Deen show where
you tuned in and you got to learn so
much more fact Islam is not a new
religion Islam has been there since time
immemorial with the first man Adam and
it continued on through all the
messengers that God sent they all call
people to the same way of life submit to
the one God do the good that he wants
you to do they gave the glad tidings of
paradise don't attach yourself to
something as temporary attach yourself
to something that's permanent and the
only way you can get to paradise is by
doing God's will doing the good things
that God Almighty wants you to do and
God don't want you to go to extremes God
doesn't want you to do things that will
harm yourself a society God wants you to
be the best example for society and
Muhammad peace be upon him is not the
founder of Islam he's just a last and
final messenger in a line of messenger
you might know some of these messengers
Noah Abraham Jesus peace be upon him
they were all messengers of God they
were all Muslim because they submitted
their will to the one God and you're
learning so much and you'll continue to
learn more just continue to tune in here
to the Deen show and until next time
peace be unto you